mécontentement des enseignants
mécontentement également des retraités
qui ont manifesté cet après-midi dans de
nombreuses villes de france à l'appel de
910 cas en pleine crise sanitaire les
revendications sont multiples précarité
pouvoir d'achat défense des services
publics notamment à l'hôpital ou encore
difficultés d'accès à la vaccination
anti copie de 19
les précisions de david khalifa depuis
le ministère des solidarités et de la
santé à paris un rassemblement qui s'est
terminée vers 15h30 ici devant le
ministère de la santé ils étaient entre
150 et 200 à répondre à l'appel des
unions confédérales de retraités une
action placée sous le signe de la
solidarité intergénérationnelle à
l'occasion de dénoncer à des inégalités
et qui se sont accentuées avec la crise
sanitaire mais qui existait déjà
auparavant
les syndicalistes réclamaient une
revalorisation de leurs pensions jugées
beaucoup trop faible à titre d'exemple
de nombreux retraités vivent avec un peu
moins de 1000 euros par mois en france
qui accentue un peu plus le taux de
pauvreté pour ces catégories d'âge
il a atteint les 6 % pour les soixante
et soixante dix ans et elle passe à 8 %
pour les plus de 75 ans et des syndicats
d'autres professions se sont également
rendus ici pour soutenir ce mouvement
mais également des politiques notamment
député de la france
insoumise c'est le cas de benoit test
syndicats secrétaire général du syndicat
fsu et dans le brillant 1,4 nans débuté
la france insoumis fonds repose de les
écouter
tout ce qu'on doit porter aujourd'hui en
termes de protection des retraités des
personnes âgées en termes de pouvoir
d'achat parce que ce sont des personnes
et des citoyennes et des citoyens qui
ont le droit de vivre de vivre décemment
avec de l'argent qu'ils n'ont pas volé
avec au contraire des droits qu'ils ont
acquis pendant leur leur travail tout ça
il faut continuer à le marteler à le
dire et compris par des mobilisations
parce que on est inquiet des
possibilités que ont continué à dégrader
le pouvoir d'achat des retraités
beaucoup réclament 300 euros
d'augmentation des pensions de retraite
c'est une juste revendication
et puis après au delà il ya la question
notamment aussi de l'accès au vaccin qui
se pose parce que parmi les retraités
beaucoup souhaiteraient pouvoir se faire
vacciner pouvoir avoir accès aux vaccins
et compte tenu de la politique d'
emmanuel macron complètement hasardeuse
de la gestion calamiteuse de la
stratégie vaccinale beaucoup de celles
et ceux qui aimeraient à 7h pouvoir se
faire vacciner ne le peuvent pas parce
que nous n'avons pas assez de vaccins
l'objectif des organisations syndicales
présentes à ici c'était également de
dénoncer le manque criant des
établissements de santé en france et a
réclamé une création d'emplois pour les
hôpitaux pour les ehpad et les services
d aide à domicile afin d'éviter une
nouvelle hécatombe
créé par le co by 19 notamment l'année
dernière un rassemblement donc statique
à paris mobilisation également à lyon et
à marseille plusieurs centaines de
retraités ont défilé tout à l'heure de
la porte d'aix en direction de l' agence
régionale de santé ars jugée
incompétente dans sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire par les manifestants
réaction de certains d'entre eux au
micro d'isabelle ferrière
les années 70 80 81 90 ça allait les
retraites était bien ça leur plaît pas à
ceux du gouvernement alors il nous reste
les retraites
il va nous qu'on revienne à la pauvreté
est d'ailleurs une grande partie des
retraités sont pauvres
je sais pas ce qui va nous arriver après
si on ne réussit pas notre combat pour
éviter que cette perdition des retraite
bien méritée des travailleurs des pays
riches
on nous accuse de sacrifier la jeunesse
d'arrêter l'économie au nous
discriminons nous infantilise on nous
culpabilise et nous disons que ça suffit
puisque si vous voulez tout ça c'est
pour masquer justement ce qui est en
train de se passer c'est à dire le
manque de tout